where are we what is this is challenge
mode challenge mode is a series of
levels where you start with something in
this area sometimes you start with
nothing in this area you're given a case
of parts and stuff over here so this
will have any number of things in it and
basically we're just supposed to get
from here to the goal and so weight
doesn't have this but mark because you
and I are guests in your inventory you
should have a toilet which is where
where you sit sure all right I believe
you come on put your toilet up here how
do I rotate it out of you next to it
[Laughter]
anyway what you'll you know you'll see
oh my goodness something seems to be
missing from this car right a toilet
seat hey Mark you want to see the best
place to put your toilet seat yeah well
it's too late but okay hang on I'll let
you so you want to be front buddies yeah
if you don't mind I mean I don't know we
could I'll do straight next to you no
problemo
now wait be aware our brains are
currently at risk and exposed
oh you can fall oh don't worry it's
magic what's wrong with this bad boy he
seems whoops the steering column I think
the students not seeing what the problem
is if your third slot is a connection
tool oh you can see all the connections
so you gotta have the steering wheel
connected to the tourney bearings and
you gotta have it connected to the
engine so you can do the gas and the
brakes also it's totally worth spending
a lot of time on you can paint things in
this game load for free Wow
red mobile are
and a little pink on the front a little
wharfs ash on the front you know if you
don't mind
oh don't worry the Shan against will
ensue I know this is not never seen how
a car is built in this game and I played
it for three hours with you guys
really yeah what I was forming yelling
about the robots ten hours until robots
come kill us how do you know that
there's a timer on my plants it says see
about the robots I've pissed you for a
reason so what's wrong with this one
wait I already put the engine in it's
all done Nevermore you know I'll just
you know what it's all the next time you
drive put your toilet alright the toilet
you driving you to smell the next one
I'm driving
alright thanks hold you drive the next
one thanks bet your power is not high
enough
alright we're doing this in one shot
boys hmm
that engine is powerful hey wait give
you a reset us mark would you like to
put the engine on what would I do it
it's in the chest this is the big arrow
pointing down to it how do you guys know
all of this oh and hang on wait do you
want to reset this nothing happened it's
fine
mmm what's the lever there's a lever
here it's a hint so it's showing you the
engine right and it's like you need to
turn the power up on the engine but not
all the way not all the way I did not
put it all the way so now that your
connector later oh I'm doing all right
okay mark to the back eaching dear
learned it to the back
oh it's why is it going you have to
connect the engine to the driver's seat
first or
on so what wheels notice that the wheels
the arrows are going to different
directions
they'll be pointed forward on both
weight this way there you go oh the
rotating okay listen guys yeah I went to
engineering school perfect perfect
you'll love to see it it's easy easy oh
yeah now we're getting to the go why
wait so tall
alright let's crawl it up here oh that
might not be a nice power this is really
how they made a tutorial for their
broken physics engine and they're like
as a feature oh look at this hill we're
supposed to about to climb up I don't
agree with this so what does it even do
you place it's over a bearing what it is
yeah so now that bearing connects those
blocks together that's how you do
steering that's what the steering is so
now if you connect those bearings to the
steering wheel it'll just power them
that's gonna power the wood Wow today we
learned the bottom way to the true
engineers thank you no no I don't like
it I'm the one calling out all the
illogical miss can I steal these and is
this still structurally sound
there that's what physics is supposed to
be yeah sure that's physics oh wait you
mean that bearing does actually rotate
that block of wood there so the bearing
in between the inner and outer blocks of
wood will rotate the wood like as a
pivot point oh I didn't know that I
thought the wood was just slapped glued
on there oh that makes more sense
but it's actually connected by the
bearing okay this is this is now
physically sound I declare the physics
appropriate mark doth declare doth
declare it physics approved and I think
we can do this yeah yeah why engineering
can't possibly be bad can I try one
thing yeah I want to connect the
bearings that are on the rotating parts
to the steering and see if that physics
approved man physics approved now I have
full control let's face we're going it's
fine we're going okay now turn oh I
turned don't even question me on that
you just have to bounce it a little look
all right now we just got to do it down
and then a much bigger sure this will be
fine do we have a time limit no it's
just like the fastest you can do it is
preferable this is the fastest possible
this is the optimal solution is physics
Lord cannot question that the genius I
didn't want to flaunt it I like mingling
with the regular people
there we go there we go you straight up
the mouse to a problem as an arrow the
wind of God compels us this is hey God
what if we go up this way yeah see this
is how it's designed to work in many
ways it's an AM be upside down us so
someone else want to try and change up
that front everything here Marco tossing
some stuff for you yeah let a real man
take care of this
bad boy here actually wait genius its
genius strike it's genius o'clock oh my
god yeah what a machine yeah now you're
jealous now you're jealous you solved
the steering issues and one fell thing
exactly Punk exactly yep we're ready
let's split you draw you drive mark I
think you deserve you're right yeah I'm
ready
now we're ready and just as an aside
just as an aside I'll crank this thing
up to now yeah overdrive now we're gonna
set some records here we go I think we
should put the back wheels up to max
power
but how will be a little more relaxed
die that is actually I set that up as a
test and you passed I'm the very brave
you ah teacher are you proud of me call
me sensei please serenade the trick that
you all missed you're not ready to learn
you're not ready clearly not ready we
just need to turn the back wheels off I
think having powered back wheels is
making us launch awkwardly off the ramp
you might be right I did this already
well I just turned the power all the way
down I'm just sorry off we're basically
on skids now
hmm that may have been my fault you know
what that may have been my fault I think
it was actually son say yep me know you
asked I answered told you to forgive me
you a-hole such thing oh wait no inline
interior you're right that is what I was
doing the whole time that is what I was
in fact doing you're you're just testing
us I know I love testing you are we
ready oh look at how really it this
machine is yes is self-correcting - yes
yeah this angles that such an angle I
know right elegant I hope you're taking
notes
hold up daddy then say not daddy
oh yes yes come on please ooh
boys look at the map over here look at
what we got going on what do we have
going on I mean sensei and douchebag oh
all right I went too far the other way
I'm sorry
that's a Edie honk man I mean teacher oh
please please please call me daddy all
right no I think you guys got this you
guys got it take over see if you can
execute what you learn this one wait I
got spectacular last round Hey you're
such a hunk of a man I think you could
do it hunk man have you tested your
steering oh dear you know I wish my
toilet my toilet seat had seatbelts so I
could really buckle myself in for an
intense [ __ ] you know if I ever have
kids I just hope that I pull pranks like
that like I'll put a seat belt on the
toilet seat and I'll teach him
no you do something like that you know
the first day of school they walk into
the bathroom teacher walks them over the
bathroom they come back out three
seconds later like you can't do it safe
if you're not buckled in yeah we'll just
put power on all the wheels wasn't it
already on all the wheels cuz I did that
maybe was before I moved them about this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah got a point get alright I
got this one
wait don't even question it this is
exactly as I intend this will be it's a
purpose-built machine there's a button
you want to press the button right you
got me feel me I feel something
now we're just gonna make a little a
little booper you know what I mean I
like the boat Burke are you finishing
the delicious paint job no I just like
to see the action when it happens
oh yeah
the most flawless execution that was
ungodly what if what I am the master now
you have nothing to teach me sir says my
god
words are done grovel at my feet
suspension worthless man I grow all
right I got this one guys you just sit
back and relax
I like this compact I like it yeah I'm
well I'm thinking more like a spider you
know I draw my inspiration from real
world creatures so it hits a bump it
just springs into the air yeah random no
that won't work
wait I'm an idiot why would this work
[Laughter]
reading a comic book
I'm sorry for my inappropriate laughter
[Laughter]
comic you're giggling at oh goodness oh
can I sit on the part that's tears Oh
Bobby you want to sit on the part that's
tears Bobby will never refer to himself
as Bobby again Bobby wants it on front
no well it stands yeah look at that
steering tests technically this is
amazing it's working perfectly
I'm fairly certain your long shocks in
the front are not attached to anything
because that bottom bar is not attached
to anything but that's your business
good catch good catch hey even masters
make mistakes
teaching Wilson every mistake is an
opportunity to learn
[Laughter]
but it's ok it's ok listen it'll be a
two in line here we go now oh that's
I don't know how from that to this left
out your left window you'll see grandmas
of the workshop oh we're not done you
you made them perfectly wide perfect
smooth solid minute forty seconds
Ceylan minute thirty nine thank you
Oh thrusters hey where did the good part
guys yeah Bob do you want to you want to
see my you want to see yeah yeah oh no
ready to succeed on the very first
attempt yep yeah we got it perfectly
symmetrical symmetrical okay reset this
reset this this needs to be slightly
more complicated I've got a solution I
got a solution all right you ready boys
yeah yeah no don't worry
hang on we got some Emmett I think it'll
help if like we're both like assistants
of the steering that'll dampen that'll
dampen the thrust control alright this
will work hang on I have a plan
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what feels good when you really
persist and you really just come up with
something that's brilliant
yeah I am impressed and I respect Oh God
from layer to layer thrusters get way
more complicated I'm glad you gave me
the easy one
Oh rotating right my turn Bob does that
history now it's your turn you know what
you're right you're right and you're
lucky then I'm here for this one do I
have a like a tendency to make
spider-like vehicles is this like it's
because you've mastered the art it's
your signature right you're right you're
right you're right
alright wait I left a toilet seat for
you in the oh it's tall hey she fires no
one touch a goddamn thing here we go
three two one
a lot of power touching the engines and
think they're doing me a favor
I swear to God I thought I touched the
edge' - turned it down because I looked
at it and it was on full power and I was
like yeah yeah yeah of course of course
of course what the power I'm wiring the
button to my seat you okay yeah yeah
you're in charge of the job I'll leave
it up to your judgement you don't II
don't wait for my signal all right do
this one somehow you knew that I wanted
you to press and never let go I felt it
was for good what you were sending the
vibe you were sending to me there's a
hint this one but I have a much better
way to oh my Chad is informing me that
Wade has not gone in a while I mean
funny interesting it's almost like we've
done two rocket levels Bob did the first
I did the second and we're on the third
can I get some counterbalance on here
other toilet have her yeah yeah yeah
yeah I got you I got you
wait I think you know what I want
I don't what I'll guess perfect I want
our legs touch yeah man of course I am
are you guys a blast-off to do this
level in the coolest possible way you do
whatever you want to do mark and I'll do
it
[Music]
maybe it's just maybe it was piloting
error maybe then maybe it was I didn't
mess with your engine power this time it
was on full already the brain damage is
interesting
oh yeah I think this will work not you
think a lot of acknowledged
okay if it's a spinning that's the
problem then clearly we need to be Oh
true that's true
you know what binning we need to be
closer to the axis of spin this is this
is coming together yeah all right
exactly how space was meant to be gotten
to
it's more stable this can't possibly
take us backwards again
it took us backwards again it's a it
it's the space shuttle it hangs on the
belly of the booster oh you're right
you're right when you're right you're
right so close man is beautiful - yeah
are we oh I just need to get the burn
timing right right are you supposed to
do this
wait we get a reset oh my god
spaceship v2 coming up boys
all right who's ready for a stupid safe
successful ride up a wall I there's
still no guarantee that's gonna happen
but okay no we're about to see hundred
percent all right mmm no you know what
no I'm shouting no again physics is the
physics Lord I'm gonna have to I don't
have to do something here right nice and
safe oh you love it oh you'll love it
all right okay let's come back I had
just done this like a non idiot we would
be done already
can I just hang myself
[Laughter]
yeah I like to be this beard like a mist
divine happens perfect beautiful see it
that was good
[Laughter]
fine yeah bill boy oh this is oh boy oh
yeah this one really hard all you have
to do is not be me you got it
hello goddamnit
we're good I highly doubt that no no
we're good we're good
Dejan toilet seats I gave you a little
side panels for your seats I just want
to watch you when you work Oh in the
first person and really get a good look
at him there is look at this pecs
pointy pecs PEC more like it but there
is one PEC all across this chest
oh I did why we have no power oh I also
didn't boost the engine hang on was your
hand in the wrong place why is the
switch hooked up to mark see there Bob
Bob I did it I'm the one yes you've
caught me it's always me the whole time
I just for my own enjoyment that when we
said it's coming back it would even try
it back
it doesn't even try you know yeah it's
cool full turn those up all right are
those Jets at full power or not at full
power
I'll offer out they have a separate
power thing same to mess with this
thrusters much thing my goodness Bob
this amateur here alright wait you got
this whoa okay the engine I see
I see all my misdeeds are coming back to
haunt me this is me the nefarious
trickster again I'm far you take - yes -
that's accurate
come on keep that going Oh baby this is
what you like to see that's what you
like to see I honestly thought that
there was gonna be gaps so we had to
boost across oh wow all right there I
had my turn turns off I remember this
one I'm not gonna tell you the answer to
this car long enough and spindly enough
[Music]
no nose no nose
no bones get your connection tool out
[Laughter]
and mixed at - static legs then have to
walk e legs the motors on the bearings
for the front legs just a lot of rip
she's a wild one you said it yourself I
yield to your aggressive expertise you
ready to make history mom wait I need
steering I forgot you guys thank you
thank you before you hit the gas I just
want to see where you're steering does
oh now you're good all right okay now
reverse all right we're getting there
we're getting there we're making
progress to the front leg so we can
experience do we have any more wood I
think I can really do something here oh
yeah that was the issues kept hidden
itself you know what the almost be like
[Music]
you know what scoops okay you ready for
this I am oh my gosh whoa girl whoa
[Applause]
[Laughter]
she's stuck boys we noticed one more
theory hmm and it's it just it goes a
little something like this yes got it
kind of you know what I mean oh I see I
see exactly what you're going for here
is it gonna is she gonna stay you know
yes I don't wonder if this is the way I
gotta be honest would you guys like to
know the a clue about the puzzle will
puzzle that's not it hmm the thing on
the left is a sensor and it likes to see
the color on the right whoo it likes
blue maybe the blue should be on the
stallion hmm also we gonna reset and get
rid of this above okay let's get out of
here let's go boys let's go home doo doo
doo dude dude I assumed something was
gonna happen if you we tested see if the
blue is at the right level for the
sensors it's no no no we don't you silly
wait for the love of God get out of the
way all right yeah that's more like it
blue do we need to wait it might still
be just a hair too low no it's got no
that's right no maybe that's a shade
lighter I I don't know that Oh
the wrong you know when the developers
made this challenge you know they
probably push it over my god just go
straight this is a trigger this thing
right here that you pass through closes
the door in the end so we need speed you
guys want to see the top top thrill
dress I want to see everything drag rail
coming in hot I do I have a special
surprise in store for the the steering
situation on this month masterpiece
monster monster piece why do they allow
this what's happening why is this alone
that's probably not the most stable
thing if I if I could request an initial
ride on this platform for your for your
little baby seats but we can do an
initial ride and I'd like to see what
the view would be like all right I'm
feeling pretty good about this
I think what we need is double the
amount of thrusters okay you're right I
hope you performs for your little seats
but that's fine that's fine yeah you
need front wait who's ready for this
baby I'm having I think this is the
winning combination I think I just did
it wrong
three two one winning it's maybe the
ability to steer might be valuable seems
normal to me is this not good no this
seems great
seems right to me seems right like a
little lean to the left to proud but
that's natural all right cool hey that's
nice man [ __ ] this no it's fine
your turn how do you flip it wait your
turn
do you collaborate on this one no you
got it okay well paint it happy buddy
yeah I got I got my paint gun ready to
rock I'm gonna paint it gold color I was
thinking the same thing I literally got
the gold at the exact same time it's out
already hell yeah let's do it
don't worry we'll paint this right up
boy these fumes Oh God oh it's an
atrocity it's a war crime um yeah yeah
it's yeah wait I would never question
the wisdom of your design you know what
I'm not gonna question it I think you're
right mark I'm not gonna question it all
right you're like I'm crazy because
I feel like I'm seeing an obvious
problem here yeah well me I try Wade
knows that yeah yeah he does
oh all right here we go all right it's
just a safety feature that it gets
caught like this just so you don't get
sticky house this next part gonna go oh
just like that hmm
oh okay well it's locked that's what you
want yeah everybody hop back on
everybody hop back on okay okay don't
need to fix the thing I know what I did
so now we're gonna make this a little oh
no don't don't don't do that don't do
that baby see if we can't flip maybe
it's a inverse oh okay I think Wade
might be a genius he might be you know
well okay or not you might as well have
maybe Oh
genius right correct you guys are saying
blaster you had it exactly right except
we were 10 feet short and you could have
backed up way further than you did to
gain more speed for the jump oh that's
fair this is even bigger brain than I
ever imagined this is there we go
oh why did the beer why did it beer why
did it fear to the left I got it
I just you didn't why oh you gotta wait
I like the mounting of the wall
procedurally magnetic yeah yeah perfect
I mean this is far enough you can maybe
just do it here and you angle it a
little to the left that's that's how you
do it come back Oh
Oh were you trying to use the Jets as a
break underside of it
an attack angle on that whoa genius
takes two steps forward two steps back
every time why is one of your jets
attached to that pivot did you notice
that Bob just his right turn your right
turn wigs
turning cuz you attach the Jets to it oh
did I all right let's do backup goddamn
you no more all the way what has been
the problem we've not had enough speed
until we're in the air turns that
explains a lot of our issues do you
think the haze of pain is affecting our
judgment at all right now hmm
perfect that's how they have been
turning that's about right yeah ideal
but you know what who needs it we'll
make it work
that's the way it have to be nominal one
of those thrusters didn't work like the
others that's okay oh you know just go
just goes go for it just go alright
nevermind
I have concerns about your piloting sir
should I feel like the design is
flawless and the execution yes I would
is flawed
I would Osio path why holds us to the
ground so you don't bounce around like
that thank you for turning the Jets on
I'm sorry I called you a sociopath it's
okay I'll leave them on until it's time
to fly this is the way that's big energy
right there okay good and conveniently
at this nightmare of a level I have to
go work ah it's a damn shame Wow you
know I would have I would have I have
the perfect plan for it it's executed in
my brain already I practically at the
finish line so yeah but through your
process that take you long it's a
multi-step process well I would hope so
yeah it is is there any clues you can
give us as to you know you gotta build a
car what was that
I can't say it again all right cool
anyway good game great job good plays
out there all right
[Music]